j'avais un frère
il s'appelait frédéric comme mes frères
et soeurs et moi c'était un enfant de la
maltraitance très grande pour pauvreté
famille très nombreuse onze enfants
alcoolisme de mon père violence verbale
violences physiques internement
psychiatrique régulier de mon père et
dans ce monde où le froid la peur
l'humiliation
le manque tenait les premières places
dans ce monde qui ne nous faisait pas de
cadeau frédéric a eu droit un supplément
un bonus il était le premier à être
placé par mon père dans un foyer de la
dass je les revois tous les deux dans la
grande pièce mon père assis sur un banc
en train de signer les papiers mon frère
de l'autre côté
hagard stupéfait ne comprenant pas ce
qui lui arrivait et mon frère est passé
de la maltraitance familiale au
maltraitance institutionnelle passage de
foyer en foyer errance violence
délinquance et au bout la case prison
dans ce parcours trop écrit al avance
comme une fatalité
dans ce parcours chaotique à un moment
une condamnation mais pas une
condamnation à l'enfermement une
condamnation à des travaux d'intérêt
général et voilà frédéric qui se
retrouvent manoeuvre sur un chantier
imaginez une grande plaine de la
champagne qu'on appelait encore
pouilleuse battu par les vents et
frédéric avec sa brouette qui charrie
toute la journée de la terre comme font
les forçats dans les films
renouant sens de savoir avec l'histoire
de notre père qui avait connu pendant
des années un bagne d'enfants mais ça
n'était pas n'importe quel chantier il
s'agissait en fait d'un chantier de
fouilles préventives
vous savez comme on en fait quand on
construit un nouvel équipement ou quand
on fait passer une autoroute et
l'archéologue qui étaient là a accueilli
frédéric mais n'a pas regardé comme un
délinquant il l'a regardé comme
n'importe quel membre de son équipe
il l'a accueilli lui a expliqué le
travail et frédéric petit à petit s'est
intéressée à l'archéologie
ces passionnés et lui qui était en échec
scolaire qui avait arrêté ses études en
sixième à repasser un à un des diplômes
jusqu'à passé une maîtrise archéologie
et le voilà quelques années plus tard
archéologues chef de fouilles par quel
miracle
comment est ce possible
le regard d'un homme
frédéric s'est sentie accepté il s'est
senti
regardez il a senti un intérêt sincère
et cette seule attention ce seul regard
a provoqué en lui quelque chose
frédéric est entré en résilience alors
la résilience qu'est ce que c'est la
résilience et une capacité à faire face
quand le drame arrive à se reconstruire
et à rebondir la résilience d'une sorte
de pouvoir personnel que nous avons
chacun et qui va nous permettre de nous
transformer dans la difficulté
la résilience un peu comme disait
alchimiste transformer le plomb et en
fer de l'or transformer les difficultés
et en faire des ressources
boris cyrulnik qui a popularisé le
concept de résilience en france
utilisent pour la décrire une très jolie
expression dont il a fait le titre d'un
de ses livres
ils appellent ça un merveilleux malheur
un malheur qui nous enseigne mais
attention la résilience c'est pas un
état il n'y a pas un gène de la
résilience ya pas ceux qui sont
résilients et ceux qui ne le serait pas
non la résilience se sont pas des
personnes qui seraient particulièrement
courageuse les héroïnes ou des héros
solitaire des capitaine flam du
traumatisme ou des harry potter qui
ferait disparaître comme ça par magie
l'adversité
non les résilient ce sont des personnes
comme vous comme moi simplement dans la
difficulté
à un moment quand tout est si noir si
difficile ils savent voir dans
l'environnement quelque chose quelqu'un
une main tendue et il la saisisse
frédéric ne savais pas qu'il était
résident vous dans cette salle tous à
des degrés divers
vous avez eu à faire face
à des difficultés à des traumatismes à
des coups durs perte d'un proche
maladies graves
abandon harcèlement au travail pertes
d'emplois faillite violences conjugales
divorce maltraitance pendant l'enfance
chacun d'entre vous a eu à faire face à
se reconstruire à rebondir et vous ne
vous êtes pas forcément dit et vous
n'avez pas forcément mis le mou de
résilience et vous n'avez pas forcément
identifié qu'il y avait quelqu'un
pourtant et pour vous faire une première
idée de ce que sont les tuteurs de
résilience
demandez vous pendant ces difficultés
qui étaient là pour vous qui ne vous
jugez pas qui vous à regarder autrement
qui ne s'est pas découragée dans vos
échecs dans vos errements les tuteurs et
résilience on va les rencontrer
généralement dans la famille proche ou
dans la famille élargie
on va les rencontrer beaucoup dans les
institutions dans les métiers de
l'accompagnement
ça va être un psychologue ça va être un
éducateur ça va être un mentor on les
rencontre beaucoup dans le monde
associatif
les responsables associatifs sportifs
culturels l'éducation populaire
pour moi c'était une institutrice
on vivait dans cette champagne dans un
petit village un petit village
d'agriculteurs
mes parents n'étaient pas agriculteur on
vivait en marge on était très pauvre
on était parfois sales et nous étions en
butte aux moqueries aux humiliations aux
agressions au coût de nos camarades
notamment lorsqu'on allait à l'école
et dans cette école j'avais 8 ans
j'étais au cours préparatoire et là y
avait une institutrice et cette
institutrice avait sur moi un regard je
le sentais je sentais sa bienveillance
je sentais son intérêt sincère je
sentais sa préoccupation pour moi
à telle enseigne qu'un jour un après
midi d'automne
elle nous dit demain nous ferons de la
science naturelle et donc vous allez
venir chacun avec un marron nous
arrivons lendemain très fiers tous
chacun avec notre marron nous faisons le
cours de sciences naturelles elle nous
distribue un petit pot en verre on
confectionne une étiquette qu'on colle
sur le pot en verre avec notre prénom on
met du coton à l'intérieur qu'on humilie
fille et on met le marron dans le petit
pot de verre et puis quelques jours
quelques semaines passent et les marrons
germes et petit à petit le pouce un
marronnier apparaît et alors hazard le
marron que j'avais apportées s'est mis à
pousser très vite et le marronnier
grandi l'institutrice me dit patrick ton
marronniers et grandit c'est super mais
il va bientôt être trop grand pour le
pot je vais le planter dans mon jardin
qui était attenant à l'école communale
quand elle me dit ça j'ai d'abord eu une
interrogation ensuite j'étais fier et
ensuite
j'ai senti la joie et puis semaine après
semaine mois après mois année après
année elle m'a donné des nouvelles du
marronnier qui avait planté ses racines
qui grandissait qui s'épanouissait je
peux vous dire que simplement quand je
vous raconte cette histoire je sens
encore aujourd'hui la fierté en moi je
sens son amour et je sens la force
qu'elle m'a donné à ce moment là et qui
fait qu'aujourd'hui je suis sociologue
intervenants hec auteurs mais ce n' est
là alors comment expliquer qu'un
archéologue puisse sauver un homme en
acceptant qu'une institutrice puis se
transformer le chemin d'un enfant en
s'occupant de lui et en l'aimant et bien
pour comprendre le mécanisme qui est à
l'oeuvre dans le processus et léché les
tuteurs de résilience je vous propose de
re passer par une expérience une
expérience scientifique est réalisée aux
etats-unis en 1968 il ya deux chercheurs
qui sont là s'appelle rosenthal et
jacobson il travaille sur l'intelligence
des rats alors ils en font pas passer
des tests de qi pour travailler sur
l'intelligence des rats en fait on fait
un labyrinthe on met un fromage ont fait
courir les rats et puis on voit le temps
qu'ils mettent pour trouver le fromage
ils prennent 12 rats ils les séparent de
manière totalement aléatoire en deux
groupes de syrah il confie le premier
groupe de 6,1 à un groupe d'étudiants et
leur disent vous savez c'est rare ils
sont aussi de transformation et de
lignage génétique on les a préparés pour
des expériences importantes il faut que
vous attendiez à ce qu'ils aient
vraiment des performances
exceptionnelles nous avons besoin de
vous en occuper d'eux pendant plusieurs
semaines et puis ils vont confier les
six autres rats un autre groupe
d'étudiants et vont leur dire vous savez
ces reins en fait on les avaient élevées
on pensait qu'on allait faire des
expériences mais en fait on sait pas ce
qu'on va en faire
ils sont pas en très bonne santé ce
serait bien que vous en occuper
on revient quelques semaines plus tard
et ont fait le test du labyrinthe et on
s'aperçoit que les rats du premier
groupe sans plus rapide pour aller
chercher le fromage les rats du second
groupe non seulement sont plus lents
mais certains ne passe même pas la ligne
de départ alors les chercheurs se disent
mais c'est incroyable que s'est il passé
simplement les étudiants du premier
groupe ont crû à la qualité de leurs
rats ils ont cru à leur potentiel ils
les ont nourris ils ont soigné avec
cette croyance là il leur en donner de
l'affection et ça a transformé
physiologiquement les reins ça fait
augmenter leur niveau de performance
alors on a recommencé la même expérience
avec des enfants je vous rassure on les
a pas mis dans un labyrinthe
ça se passe dans la banlieue de san
francisco banlieues défavorisées
une école primaire qui s'appelle max
poule qui accueille beaucoup d enfants
issus de l'immigration
certains ont des problèmes linguistiques
des problèmes de niveau etc
il se présente en indiquant qu'ils font
une grande étude pour l'université de
harvard sur l'émergence de
l'intelligence tardive
ils ont donc besoin de faire passer les
tests depuis à tous les enfants et de
revenir une année plus tard et de
vérifier si c'est toujours pareil ils
font passer les tests de qi mais ensuite
pour chaque classe
ils choisissent par tirage au sort cinq
élèves à qui ils affectent 20.2 cuisse
supplémentaire ils en fois l'ensemble
des résultats qu'ils ont donc modifié
aux enseignants et 10 aux enseignants
pour être sûr que les enseignants crois
vraiment aux résultats qu'ils sont
vraiment désolé que on leur a envoyé par
erreur un an plus tard ils reviennent on
refait passer les tests de cuillé aux
enfants
que s'est il passé tous les enfants qui
ont été sélectionnés au hasard et se
sont vu attribuer 20 points de plus ont
augmenté leur niveau de qi mesurer avec
le même test de 5 à 25 points en un an
ce résultat qui peut paraître miraculeux
est aujourd'hui clairement référence et
il ya eu des dizaines d'études qui ont
été faites pour vérifier l'existence de
phénomènes de ce phénomène qui s'appelle
la prophétie auto réalisatrice
c'est à dire que la croyance que j'ai
sur l'autre ce que je pense de sa valeur
de ses qualités de son potentiel va se
réaliser on appelle également cet effet
l'effet pygmalion
parce que finalement les tuteurs de
résilience ce sont des personnes qui par
leur regard
par leur attitude par leurs croyances
personnelles sur l'autre vont déclencher
chez l'autre un processus
la personne se voit plus intelligente
plus belle plus forte et déclenche en
elle un processus de croissance comme le
marronnier ils ont un certain nombre de
caractéristiques
la première des caractéristiques c'est
qu'ils ont ce regard particulier ils ont
un intérêt sincère pour l'autre la
deuxième des caractéristiques c'est
qu'il laisse la liberté à l'autre de
venir à eux de s'exprimer ou pas à telle
enseigne que quand j'étais délégué
général d'emmaüs france
la consigne était de ne jamais
interroger un compagnon sur son histoire
et sur ces drames mais il était pas rare
qu'un compagnon travaillant à côté d'un
bénévole d'un coup ce que tous se
confient raconte une tragédie et parce
qu'il se sentait écouté et entendu
pouvait se transformer les résilient ne
juge pas du chemin choisi pour faire son
parcours de résilience
ça peut être par le voyage ça peut être
par la fois ça peut être par le
militantisme culturel social
ça peut être par la création ça peut
être par l'entrepreneuriat ça peut être
en faisant tedx peu importe le chemin
les tuteurs de résilience ont encore une
autre caractéristique c'est qu'ils ne se
découragent pas pourquoi ils savent que
la résilience est un processus et donc
les errances les échecs ne sont que des
étapes les tuteurs de résilience donne
confiance à l'autre parce qu'ils ont ce
regard particulier cette compassion
cette humanité qui fait que l'autre se
sent beau se sont grands
a de la valeur les tuteurs de résilience
savent voir en l'autre les qualités même
si elles sont pas visibles
c'est ce qui est arrivé à tim guénard à
l'âge de deux ans il est abandonné par
sa mère son père est alcoolique violent
et lui brisent les deux jambes il passe
deux ans à l'hôpital
il est ensuite placée dans une
institution où il va subir des abus
sexuels
il devient délinquant on fera moins et
un jour ils se retrouvent dans le bureau
d'un commissaire et indiana raconte dans
son livre plus fort que la haine que le
regard de ce commissaire le fait que ce
commissaire l'a regardé pour qu'il était
humainement a su voir en lui au delà du
délinquant
le jeune révolté perdu souffrent et
qu'il ait su voir aussi le potentiel de
croissance qui avait dans ce jeune homme
ce seul regard ces quelques instants ont
changé sa vie aujourd'hui tim guénard et
est auteur éducateurs et il anime un
centre d'accueil pour des jeunes en très
grande difficulté dans le sud
alors vous voyez finalement chacun
d'entre nous chacun d'entre vous quel
que soit votre parcours
quelles que soient vos richesses vous
pouvez être là pour quelqu'un vous
pouvez être là pour l'autre que ce soit
un proche que ce soit un inconnu
bien entendu vous ne saurez pas
forcément ce que votre regard
votre sourire votre mot aura fait mais
c'est bien comme ça c'est là être
quelqu'un et pour finir j'ai envie de
vous reposer la question peut-être
pouvez-vous si vous le souhaitez
l'espace de quelques instants fermer les
yeux et demandez vous qui a été là pour
vous qui ne vous jugez pas qui vous a
inspiré et mais soutenu demandez vous
laisser émerger
finalement cette figure cette personne
qui est une source infinie qui ne tarit
pas et peut-être pouvez-vous ou pas
comme vous voudrez la mettre au service
d'autres merci merci d'avoir été là pour
moi